welcome to this video yeah this is some
a quick recap of the London Grand Prix
tournament which has been finished just
today today was the last round and i'll
present one game from the tournament and
also do a quick recap he at the
beginning of the whole event so I'm
starting here with the the cross table
and the shed tournament winners are on
Mammadyarov girlfriend into pallav I'm
not quite sure about them the the tie
breaks here this some fun ranking air
shows the standings the cost according
to his on a bone bag aware tone via to
vet on German wat so no bone bag I'm
tiebreak I guess in English its be kind
of weird to combine this German who
words with an English one yeah all three
players played a very good tournament
you see that to Paul off didn't lose the
game but 13 against them the tail enders
Martine and let's like like he won
against Dominguez giri and against Iran
shook um girl phone had an excellent
start with winning I think three games
early but then he lost her to Grisha
gandam was overtaken by mamedyarov we
also played excellently well he also
lost early against Grisha and then
started to win a couple of games and was
in the lead actually before the last
round and in the last round girl phone
it to pull up with winsome caught up to
him so on all three players I guess can
be very satisfied with the result I
think especially to par love had very
very tough two years after his loss in
the world championship match to town
2010 and um this is probably his first
tournament went after this I'm not one
hundred percent sure but could be could
be true yeah following his Grisha who
actually managed to beat two of the
co-leaders Mahmoud yarrow fingolfin
both in excellent games and he drew the
rest um yeah he could he just needed one
one one extra window to win the turning
he played great chess also I think maybe
it's not one hundred percent satisfied
with with this place but certainly not a
bad tournament at all liquor also played
very solidly as we are used to from him
and he won a game against even shook I'm
nice technical display and drew the rest
not shot Ross it was fighting chess but
lots of drawers anyway Wang Hao managed
to be done now can run and lost one very
funny end game against Kelvin where it
was completely drawn and he spoiled it
with the really city blunder at the end
yeah Adams on minus one same as even
shook they both had an up-and-down
tournament managed to beat the camera
but everything else so they yeah they
didn't do didn't do so well then we had
chasm jano phantom English both on- too
yeah i guess they're not satisfied but
someone needs to him he i get under snow
sir bottom bottom places in this
tournaments as you can see it is
exceptionally strong the only player
below 2700 discussing jonathan is not
far away um yeah then the both the
shared last places are really a surprise
um arnesh geary from the netherlands he
had excellent results recently but in
this tournament did what simply wasn't
to be didn't win a game and lost three
actually and yeah the the most
disappointed sir player is certainly
knock around managed to run when too
loud to lose four games in a row in the
middle of the tournament it simply was
terrible to watch this the sum this
series of bad results I am not quite
sure what happened they had great
results before but simply in this
tournament there
everything went wrong really hard too
hard to say sometimes you only done
afterwards that there was some illness
or something you you never know at least
not them if you don't have any inside
information so I'm yeah very bad
tournament fine but he's a Friday will
come back for sure okay I'm wanted to
pick one game and at the end I to some
let's close this not I I went formed we
shook against galfond at the round this
was played a couple of rounds um before
the final round today so it was in a
situation of a girl phone was leading
the tournament and rushabh really needed
to win to have some chances so let's see
what happened onee phone and girlfriend
playing c5 he really sticks to has some
preparation for the world championship
match so he played this rashly cough and
he even played the groom thought so this
wasn't a one-off father for the title
match agree shop now surprisingly placed
93 usually it just goes for the open
Sicilian but not see 396 of course this
is gavin wants to go for his lines and
he needs to play 96 for a threatening
curve i mean and here the Grisha played
the interesting move Bishop b5 this is
still up an offbeat line in a way but
it's very interesting and something i
can recommend to white players because
um it's a very tricky and black the
black camp players very often don't have
a clear idea what to do gulfam plate
night d foyer which is maybe the best
smooth there are alternatives of course
the idea of all this is the following if
black will play move like g6 here then
white can can take on c6 and then
transpose into a kind of Grand Prix
attack while you manage to exchange the
bishop on c6 this is something that
white usually doesn't manage
in the Grand Prix if you compare this
just to to show what I mean let's say
this kind of move order here like
normally place this to avoid the captcha
on c6 and this is something that he
didn't manage here as white captures
first and then plays F form so on this
is an interesting set up the critical
move is probably ninety foursome as some
golf and also played here white can if
he wants a retreat to see form but he
can also play Nadia physicist what down
what we shoved it and now girl from
plate e six he also could could have
taken on d5 which isn't bad but this is
something that involves a little bit of
a risk because of you if you look at
just oops just a sample line here on all
this 94-95 has cost black some time and
white now has a queen on d form which is
yeah not so easy to UM to do yet to get
to get away from there and you can play
a five but this would weaken double
central structure and if black plays
them some some slow moves then why does
this very quick and development it's a
bit a bit similar to the three Queen txt
for variation on 2d six but it's some
some are quicker here for white what I'm
talking about this just quickly I'm
talking about this line yeah this is
this where this is a known variation and
now compare this to what we had in the
game oops this was too quick if black
will take now
this is similar to the other line but
the other line Black has already assured
ones is six and yet white is simply
quicker okay this is why it didn't take
on b5 it is playable but not the best
move probably he just played e6 and
white now castles interesting here is if
you take on d4 which is pretty common
mistake Black has this move quite funny
double the tech and he will win a pawn
on g2 this is why why dem cannot take
and he just canceled if black would take
now on on b5 this would be a quite
similar to to be formed so it didn't do
that he played the move a 6 which is um
normal move when the slug in any way and
why do we treat it to d3 that's not that
much else it looks a bit funny to place
the the bishop here in front of the porn
but there is an idea behind all that hip
like can also play 97 he played some
layouts but let's look at 97 of them
black just continuous developing with
the idea to support his night on deform
then why would take and play here and
then C 3 this is the idea to attack the
pawn and false black at some point to to
capture and then your bishop will get
into play it can that can go on
something like this just to illustrate
and for example after this white will
get them get the bishop out finally so
it's not not a big problem that that it
is blocked at the moment but the other
place another move funny move he just
retreated the night so I've got some
some funny maneuver cm and yeah this
sort of asks why what are you doing out
with the bishop on d3 now that you
cannot take any more on d4 and crucial
grants at this question with we should
be to just dropping this Bishop back
yeah you can ask yourself now what the
hell is happening all these multiple
moves
did someone lose the tempo here yeah in
fact them this position could also arise
after five moves it's just identical to
something like let's say 96 not in 36 we
should be to e6 castles this is just the
same position only two moves less so in
the game it took took some time to get
there but we have the same position and
the funny thing about this is um yeah
probably on the normal move or normal
moves here would be Quincy 7 on let's
say d6 and all these moves after deform
would lead to a typical open Sicilian
where whitis gives gone for this Bishop
e2 line but one this is given ingen on
probably if you would go here we have a
10 month off variation and both thus
given in entertainment of our outside
girl fans repertoire he placed the night
off all you place the special ego but he
doesn't play any of this so um this is a
very funny and I guess he didn't want to
get into one of those lines so what did
he do he went died you fall back yeah
this is a game which is really am a bit
bit difficult to explain to him let's
say let's just less experienced players
because it is violating all kinds of
principles Black is just going back and
forth this is night I think you can do
this is that some slightly risky but
it's nothing nothing too bad um yeah
galfond gwent 94 and grecian just went
back so we have a repetition here and
what did galfer do he went back so we
have the same position that we had two
moves ago and here Grisha played Bishop
e2
okay but he didn't want to draw Gavin
obviously didn't mind to draw this game
he was leading the tournament so I'm
yeah what moves out there that are not
push should be too yeah that's rookie
one and b3 and ok goo shock played v3 to
fianchetto the bishop so we won't have a
quick draw very funny our first moves so
black played d 6 cm and Knight f6 just
normal moves we are back into normal
chest bit mode again rookie one um yeah
it's funny this bishop on d3 but well
it's not so so badly positioned down you
see him that what is going 45 and this
bishop has a potentially very good
diagonal so all this um make sense like
now played we should be seven year
hadn't a principled alternative he could
have played if I've also to block this
and block the bishop also I think the
problem might be 95 with white intending
to play a quick c3 probably moving the
bishop to f1 not to c4 and then d 4 why
does a much better developed after all I
think that that was what he didn't like
um still this is some setup that black
and consider because it is much safer
than the setup that was played in the
game we we see what I'm talking about he
played Bishop d7 and now Grisha 25 yeah
okay like he needs to take it 95 and now
I will see that those bishops are
potentially very strong a platen I am
Bishop d7 now and 94 yeah putting the
stag not to good use and black gum
exchange only five play Bishop c6 to get
the bishop to a good diagonal as well
and now naija have a queen to f3 yeah
now we see that
the bishops are dangerous and their
various slides to illustrate that girl
from now blade rook c8 but what would
happen if you would castle in fact this
um this losses upon surprisingly because
of nine f6 here you should have six
Bishop of six yeah Queen needs to take
now and green edge five and now we have
a double attack threatening mate and
oops yeah like us lost upon this isn't
isn't so easy to force even um gap in
fact black it's not a clear pond down it
has a bit of compensation as now the
bishop is a bit silly on d3 and this one
is oops not here yeah of course it's
pretty good it's got ideas like this
black has a bit of compensation but not
not enough for porn so it's
understandable that he didn't castle he
played a rope to see eight um but this
at least was a chance to to get castles
and now came rookie three yeah and what
now if Blackwood castle now when she
didn't do jack jack he would get
immediately destroyed with this classic
sacrifice yeah and it's over gap lai can
play all kinds of silly stuff here too
can continue the game but this this is
killing so here black cannot castle and
this is my father most natural move that
you you want to play on yeah what else
is there black can trying to prepare
castle with move like h6 but um
after this you you need to reckon with
Queen g3 maybe even now even instantly
and it's also not too comfortable at
some not easy to play this position and
so h6 doesn't help much yeah I can
consider 95 also attacking this rook but
here White has a very strongly proliant
Queen g3 and this is indeed very strong
what should like do now um he cannot
really and this is a shame diff ng7 what
what should you do you can consider very
unnatural looking moves like rook g8 but
yeah how does this fit into the overall
scheme of things of white now just move
the rootlets a hero even even all the
way back I mean what is the rook doing
on g8 and if you take on e3 then Queen
g7 is very strong for example rook f-89
f6 yeah and this is this is just
terrible for black with this this
monster Bishop just completely
controlling the whole position cannot go
rook d8 you cannot cancel anymore and
all this is weak and white can simply
improve with maybe rookie one but should
be to stuff like this and this is just
one IDM there are multiple ideas yeah 23
is very annoying on 95 so black ass a
slight trouble already he needs to be
very careful at least he played be fine
which seems ok now we should play drug a
to you one so he wanted to centralize
all pieces and you see that it's quite
funny all these pieces positioned in the
center
yeah I stood like an odd castle because
of this Knight f6 Bishop h7 business and
yeah what should he do it's really
difficult the same I'm he played them in
the game you played see form trying to
solve his problems in a technical
fashion if you look at this with the
computer and computer will tell you that
95 it's now okay for black but this is a
completely um yeah this is no human line
if you look at this now Queen g3 looks
look still very threatening but the
computer um just wants to go see form
and I guess proves an analysis that this
is okay for black but no human player
would would consider this Queen g7 rook
and fade yeah Bishop here 93 rookie 3
Bishop before looking for Queen d2 and
the computer gives this is completely
equal I looked at this a bit further and
it's probably right but then this is
simply a variation that human player
doesn't doesn't calculate mean itself
it's simply simply unrealistic um yeah
the problem is there are no simple
solutions anymore for black probably
needs to do this after c4 is some in
trouble this is clear we should talk and
not took on f6 yeah like I'm caption on
e4 this was the whole idea if you would
recapture here then it's rather
something white can just grab the spawn
and yeah we are near an endgame in fact
here it's quite nice that you haven't
moved any porn so I don't have any bond
weaknesses and yeah what is just a pawn
up like also cannot go for this
desperado here
because white has this move until a text
both to rock anthem and the bishop on
Luca 8 oops not this one on rook aah the
sauce intermediate check and now you can
the bishop so here like it's just a pawn
down in comparison this is better than
the game that okay it took on ye form um
rookie form Bishop takes Bishop c4 yeah
now he took on t2 with the Queen this
was the whole idea of this operation but
it is based on a miscalculation probably
black he needed to to gessle and play
this position this is quite similar to
this end game from from couple of months
ago but difference is now we have got
opposite colored bishops which gives
black slide hopes that he might be able
to get into some endgame that that he
can hold but it's not outright equal or
something on this is still a weakness so
why does still a pretty clear advantage
what he needed to do this probably if
you look at the game he grabbed on d 2
yeah now grew shotgun captured only six
very strong move sacrifice and um yeah
no no way that black and cannot take it
he must take only six so rookie six yeah
and now the king is checked and where
should it go in fact the only player
will move was some here looking to oops
King to f7 I mean playable in a sense
that the game is not in not immediately
over um it's still winning but let's
look let's let's have a look Queen check
yeah black cannot retreat yeah just this
is just checkmate checkmate
so black needs to go g6 and now Queen f3
back yeah yeah yeahs having everything
on f6 and black cannot cover it this is
the unfortunate thing if you want to
cover it you've got this stuff and white
wins thous with an ongoing a techie as
two weeks reports just winning and yeah
what else is there cannot cover this um
you can you can try this this kind of
things but this is still two pawns with
another's even ship made sorry this is
in checkmate coming it to go here and
this kind of variation um yeah you just
need to cover this and then you're
probably winning two pawns black can
continue but it's two points yeah still
he needed to do that but what what you
played okay let's let's check for us the
other moves this one is simply answered
by rho k f6 and black cannot survive
this it's simply this to two pieces on
an open border too much to win this or
you get get there again it's simply over
so he'd really needed to go to have
seven what he did is and maybe maybe he
saw queen of that King f7 SS losing and
he went for this move in the game King
g7 because now white still has to find a
good move but grew shock is excellent
tactically and he found the move and
this is Queen g4 which is exceptionally
strong now what threatens discoveries
with the rook
and yeah it's over Black has no way to
save himself we can look through to
through the King moves let's say King d8
what just goes here and wins the Queen
and time forgot what he played in the
game yeah he played King c7 in the game
but you don't have don't have any any
other move let's say you would attack
the Queen then why has this check and
lambda did it simply it somebody doesn't
help let's say here and you mated or
here and this is also leading to to
check made and you're getting mated on
b7 after like has thrown in a couple of
desperado moves yeah the king is simply
hunted down now yeah in the game he went
for King c7 and you should know just
gave the check came to d7 clock and
Queen a fraud check gimme 8 yeah here
could have won a bit cooker with rook e8
he played Queen takes a 6 which it's
also completely over with this threat um
rookie aid was also winning as this this
position we had earlier are very similar
one where this one this over says
winning yes mentioned oops as mentioned
he took here but black has no way to
save him so if we can simply do nothing
about rook t6 played this Queen B 5
check king d 8 and and now the check
yeah like I'm can go here
and at the end you've got this Ruby one
check coming up so very funny King hunt
at the end at least funny for the white
player and further for the spectators
yeah I hope you enjoyed the game I think
it was fun to watch and it's not an easy
game to figure out because I'm not quite
sure where black really went totally
wrong I mean he was around here it was
was tricky and maybe he really needed to
player this weird computer move from 95
here but it's very very difficult to to
play for a human player yeah I hope you
enjoyed the video thanks for watching